so let's discuss what's behind an enlarged
prostate that could potentially affect your
urination now it is true that when men age their
prostate actually does enlarge and take a look at
where the prostate is located it's a gland that
wraps around this little tube that's coming from
your urinary bladder so as you increase the size
of that prostate it's going to shut down that tube
and it's going to affect your ability to urinate
and so the doctor puts you on a certain medication
like flomax an antibiotic and maybe you'll do some
blood tests and then i'll see you in six months
but my question is what is causing
the enlarged prostate if you take
a look at all of your hormones they can be
classified really in two different categories
one category is called anabolic and
the other category would be catabolic
now anabolic has everything to do with building
something up and catabolic is breaking something
down so when you eat food you have this
catabolic effect all these enzymes that
break down food into their basic building
blocks amino acids fatty acids glucose etc
and then you have all the anabolic hormones
that kick in and take these building blocks
and make body tissue out of them and so when the
prostate enlarges it's obvious that you have this
anabolic thing going on right if we take a look
at all the anabolic hormones we have prolactin
which and maybe you've heard of prolactin with
women in breastfeeding but men also have prolactin
and if the prolactin is too high it can
definitely increase the size of the prostate
and then estrogen itself can increase the size
of the prostate and estrogen also increases the
release of prolactin so then you have other
hormones like dht which is a very powerful
form of testosterone and androgens cortisol
growth hormone igf number one which is kind
of the extension of growth hormone it's made
by the liver it's stimulated by growth hormone
definitely will increase the prostate and you have
progesterone and insulin which is a very powerful
anabolic hormone and so let's take
a look here what food or thing
has the majority of these hormones that
you might be consuming on a regular basis
milk milk is a very powerful anabolic
substance that is turned into cheese
yogurt kefir and milk contains the majority
of these anabolic hormones and so if you
have urination problems or your prostate is
enlarged you need to get off milk and milk
products 100 percent okay that's number one
now number two is insulin what triggers insulin
sugar a high carb diet so if your prostate
is enlarged or you have urination problems
you need to get off sugar and go on a ketogenic
plan if you're new to my channel i put a link
down below and then we have estrogen okay so
estrogen can come from many different sources
soy is a big source of estrogen so
if you're consuming anything like
soy milk or soy protein isolates as a protein
and maybe a diet shake that you're taking
or you're not consuming organic foods you just
have commercial vegetables or commercial foods
which have a lot of chemicals that mimic estrogen
that could be one big factor that's increasing the
size of your prostate now a lot of times people
take natural remedies for the prostate like
salt palmetto and because salt
palmetto inhibits a certain enzyme
that is normally converting testosterone
into a very powerful form of testosterone
called dht which can increase the prostate but
here's the problem if you're taking salt palmetto
on top of consuming a lot of milk products
eating on sugar potentially consuming some soy
it's not going to work so i recommend cut out
the dairy get on a keto plan make sure you don't
consume anything that can stimulate estrogen
in addition to that take some saw palmetto
green tea is a great inhibitor of
this enzyme so are pumpkin seeds zinc
and lycopene now lycopene also has some great
research that can help shrink the prostate
and that would be high in tomatoes so tomatoes
would be a good food to consume if you have an
enlarged prostate so if you're going to tail or
make a diet to someone with an enlarged prostate
not only healthy keto and intermittent fasting but
i would also consume more cruciferous vegetables
especially kale because that's going to
help balance your estrogen and even beats
hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what
about strengthening your immune system
that's what's missing this course will show
you how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment much
better by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today